hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan Seibert
so today we're gonna check out the
Mirror's Edge catalyst gameplay trailer
yeah I'm not that familiar with this
game are you it's free running and it's
awesome good one quick grip time to make
myself useful huh where do I go you need
to make your way to the agricultural
division this looks great
[Music]
what's the help just a lot a couple of
these airlines have something an
employee what are the answer so cool
that POV oh yeah I love it
London POV we came is one of the taller
buildings you should see their logo on
the side see it something doesn't feel
right
[Music]
rerun it man this is all about here got
it
be careful don't worry Noah I got this I
just love that it's the first person oh
it was all said say what the first one -
[Music]
incredibly detail you're really a part
of this world
Kenzi
Elysium labs i profoundly regret but
they are very protective about this data
so there's no margin for error you
understand this heads up I got plenty of
commotion below and a connect motorcade
arriving enforcers everywhere what this
is not looking right at all we should
abort the run let me roll with it Noah
we do not mess with Gabriel Krueger I
need the scrip it's not like I can stop
you anyway
Icarus keep us updated on any changes
outside it's pretty speedy this is
pretty sweet
oh uh there's someone else here not a
runner I don't like this you should get
out of there sorry I'm checking it out
[Music]
there's a whole different set of labs
here this is an agricultural research
brain what are they up to
I'm finishing this no let the mirror at
the big deal I wanna deal with him
wait I needed my life
I can see why they got everyone
[Music]
eyes games watchin
[Music]
[Music]
Skiba that panting she makes is so sexy
isn't it why why you dude this guy is
why do you take like a great thing yet
Ben Ben this is a great thing a man she
sounds sexy when she's like running out
of breath and panting really hard you
know yeah like you really get into this
game the whole landscape looks [ __ ]
beautiful the city and everything it's
like an awesome sci-fi world and you're
free running in this world and the fact
that it's POV just makes it that much
more immersive do it and the best part
about that that's pre-alpha which means
it's not even like it's not even alpha
it's not even beta like that game is
gonna look [ __ ] gorgeous when it's
done oh and I'm gonna jerk off the [ __ ]
out of that guy right what's her name
faith and then like on top of that the
combat like the whole like running into
[ __ ] Michael Oh God
the combat sequences are great because
at first this is cool when she's
freerunning yeah in like no combat way
but then when like bullets are flying
and everything that was scary it was so
cool when she jumped through the mirror
she saw a reflection before then that
was dope and I think I mean one of the
big things for me is that though there
was a lot of stuff happening it still
feels like it's intimidating as a gamer
but like at the same time I feel like
I'm gonna be able to it feels like oh
man very well in-game yeah which is a
big thing for me because you see like
some trailers show a lot of like
complicated attacks or combos or
something and then you see something
like this and you're like I think I can
hit the right buttons to make yeah yeah
flipping around the edge of the corner
and taking the dude into the like
advertisement billboard thing like yeah
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
hmm you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can you cannot check out
dansgaming channel then do the cyber
channel you could follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and me on
periscope do you have a snapchat
I'll say hold up Yang's rhyme please
shout out love you huh hold up ayane's
dude I will hold up your gains while I
blow you my friend damn it
I went for a dude I mean I was gonna
make a Hanes joke what was the Hanes
joke let's hear it wasn't good just
sounds like it just sounds like a wedgie
whoo I want to blow this guy he'll is
terrifying he's Unchained Oh No what I
don't know he just looks scary he
doesn't look that scary I feel like you
just jam it down my throat ooh